cab a bank right back
I got a sorry my hotkey for this game is
like for OBS is the same as I got game
this game so it's long every got magic
what happened monsters monsters from the
swamp folks at the road was fraught with
peril but I wouldn't listen
got my cup up Isaac he's so sorry less
moaning more details what happened and
how can I help
and remember I don't play exactly I gave
her that much is coming off well was on
my way to the black ones to trade
suddenly my horse got spooked ran clear
off the road we hit a bump I went flying
and the horse and cart rolled on then I
write about slippery something came out
from the muck devourer - ax huh
no doubt my goods are still on the end
but until a fancy thought maybe you are
most concerned about a little box bring
it to me like make you Carlos - fine
I'll go now you know if I find that box
precious cargo okay let's see here
I threw that one that Kay
use the widget here it go man attack
cart tracks rode off into the swamp a
lot of critters on there
I get some of this gotta learn you know
that one hard drove off in a year that
is that here's the cart
Oh cookies oh god base
carts riddled with arrows interesting Oh
take a look around get that ad by Travis
riddled with in arrows okay where's a
little black box that
do call water
I read that
no--don't devoured this I thought they
said he devoured him an arrow didn't
mention this bra this is a trap trap of
I ever saw one square in the neck good
shot either the merchants got serious
memory problems or he's lying it's a
trap
nobody's trying to chop back
what is this
here's love by wax must be that box he
mentioned splattered with blood human
blood
what the heck happened here is this a
scam I never get to let the attack
raaah
oh and you find the box
yeah found your priceless chest and
someone who looks an awful lot like a
cart driver with an arrow through his
neck no dryads in these swamps and never
known a drowner or a water hack to use a
bow so lacking any other suspects I'm
guessing what out behind you it's a scam
there's nothing behind me I'm a Witcher
I'd have heard it just like I can hear
your heart which is pounding like a
liar's best hope you're a better writer
than you are a liar okay let's get this
brow
where's my where's my trust a horse
Daria's i Sam nice you up over here
there you shoot them
let me get close and I'll [ __ ] we're in
the friggin face okay I hate God he's
God I wear like less
now that wasn't slow
I got him I got him
well what do you have to say for
yourself got to get him out of here huh
wake up see can't run from the truth not
even on a horseback now who are you and
why do you attack that cart private
first class Jim Gilmer to Marion six
division 2nd regiment disbanded but
still active underground in the woods
that was a medical transport I'd be
damned if it reached the black ones and
the medicine our lats could use it to
we've many Hill among us you let me go
and they might live
Oh the top once more for a ride ride
yeah at idea
fine go and may you and your soldier
buddies hiding in the bushes be
victorious in your struggle against
nilfgaard with a lot of humor but you're
a decent man here the gold I promised
use it well drink to the silver spirits
like what Voltaire memory up horse
follow me
that's right anyways thanks for watching
I guess thanks for watching